this is drew's news your daily fresh
coat of the good news paint first up we
have to talk about this incredible desk
handmade for us by the one and only
restoration road star clint harp cliff
well done
well done mr harp ladies and gentlemen
well done well done look at it
it's beautiful
oh man this is great oh my god
i am so starstruck right now how do you
think i feel right i'm like playing it
really yeah i'm like good you do
understand that like i was you know
watching e.t going oh my gosh
yeah
yes
such an honor the clint drew's news desk
is all right i love it thank you so much
for honoring this good to see you clint
well done
you bet thank you look at our high
questions
and i'll be breaking it down and taking
it home with us all right let's hit some
headlines uh ross uh it's your spray
first all right we got a feel-good story
for you now okay about when a repair
project comes in way way under budget
right the good news network reports an
old 14th century church in grimsby
england had a little problem because
their clock tower was just stuck at two
past 12 for over a decade and they had
fancy clock engineers coming to town
they told them it would cost 50 000
to fix it but they thought let's try
something else first so they let two
locals take a look a student and a local
cheese maker
they went up with a can of wd-40 yeah
and they sprayed it and just like that
the clock was fixed all right
fifty thousand dollars amazing my dad
always said he'd fix anything around the
house and he said if you have a roll of
duct tape or a can of wd-40 that's all
you need that is true okay now is this
like the dream to come this far under
budget in a project oh for sure a dream
and i feel like even just sitting here i
was thinking about the silos behind us
when we bought this property
everyone was like you have to paint the
silos and then when i got the bid in for
the silos it was either the silos or
everything else you see because i
couldn't afford both
but thinking the idea that we saved so
much by leaving them the way they are
and now when i look at them i'm like i'm
so glad we didn't paint i can't even so
i saved hundreds of thousands of dollars
we're not painting those things all
right next up everyone loves to get a
taste of texas including wonderful
prince harry people reports that he was
recently spotted in fort worth wow
that's right we love fort worth
attending his very first rodeo he went
to the stockyard championship and one
coach said it was the first prince he'd
ever seen at the rodeo
now chip and joe your texas royalty have
you ever been told that you kind of sort
of have some
similarities with a harry and a meghan
there are some symmetry i love this
comparison for sure i also like
picturing him at a you know he went from
buckingham palace to buckingham bronco
can you imagine well like him in a
really like giddy up horse
i can see them anywhere now because
they're going everywhere and they're
living their dream and they broke out
and i'm just like they're the living
example of don't stay stuck
i'm in okay all right all right
next up the wall street journal reports
style is trending westward y'all
clothing retailers are noticing an
uptick in sales of cowboy boots denim
shirts
wranglers and lee jeans look we have a
male model right yeah baby
it's about time look at this pearl snap
shirt look at that
this can happen in a heartbeat it's so
funny if the moment strikes can you take
off your shirt that quickly i've been
waiting for you to ask me the whole time
oh no takes you a minute let me tell you
i would look like a village person if i
tried to wear this but you pull it off
and experts say people are itching to
get back outdoors and shows like
yellowstone might be responsible i think
a good western look has just always been
and always will be i think it's what
they call timeless
[Music]
you